the major objective is to process reeds
that
from a tissue or a collection of cells
so let's say cell culture or tissue
and then try to understand typically at
the difference between condition and
control
what are some amplified pathways or gene
sets so that's the standard approach in
rna-seq right you kind of have to create
a matrix of gene expression levels and
then you can compare and contrast
between different conditions
now in dell what happens is that the
resolution of your data
becomes much much more specific and so i
like this analogy that i heard
um that entering temperature
and averaging it across the whole
hospital right where i can say i have
dead people in the hospital in the
morgue i have people with fever very
high fever and maybe the infectious
disease department and i have average
temperature maybe in other races as well
so if i measure the average temperature
across all of these different conditions
i will get a normal temperature
but at single cell level i am going to
start to distinguish between the
departments and i can say here's my
acute patient
you know department here's the dead and
here are the normal people right so i
can start to distinguish and that is
really one of the benefits of having sex
resolution but how do we achieve that
how do we actually produce data that can
help us see some of these differences
well in
2019 i believe this paper came out that
kind of did a review of many different
methods of single cell data preparation
and you will see here how
first these were very manual methods so
methods that people had to you know take
individual kind of several cells and try
to separate them and so forth and all
the way to more and more automated
methods and so today when we look at the
data that you are typically going to
encounter
it comes from a specific machine that is
designed to optimize automate and
increase the number of cells and the
accuracy of barcoding but here you can
see that you know throughout from 2009
which the first paper that was published
on single cell is in the middle of 2009
all the way to 2017
you can see an exponential growth of the
single cell approaches and so in 2019 or
sorry in 2017 actually when this paper
was uh published uh they compiled all of
these protocols that went from you know
very manual again to more and more
automated and you can appreciate now
that whenever you take a data set that
is single cell rna-seq data it actually
could mean many different things so to
really appreciate the different
approaches that have been more or less
established over the past decade or so
maybe a couple of decades now let's take
a look at some of these basic ideas and
technologies and try to understand how
do we capture this uh precision and this
you know dimension of single cell
so one of the first
ideas
is to
differentiate between cells right if we
are going to study something at the
single cell level we need to understand
how do we differentiate between many
thousands of cells that we potentially
have to sequence
and to do that one of the ideas is to
give them a barcode so if i could
generate a barcode
for a type of cells right i'm not
generating a barcode for every
individual cell i'm just assigning them
to
maybe different tissues or different
batches or something like that
so here i have barcodes for example i
want to have a bunch of cells and i have
a tumor and i have a micro environment
right and i want to be able to
differentiate between them i can give
them a barcode
and those barcodes have to be
encapsulated
with the cell right and so if i kind of
take a droplet let's say an oil a
droplet of oil i can put a single cell
into that droplet and a barcode bead and
that barcode bead looks like this it
actually is a bead
that has these connected dna strings
attached to it
and once i prepare my data like this and
i keep them all inside the same bead now
i can sequence an individual cell
so this is the basic idea right but now
let's take a look at three different
methods i think i have here
so the first method is called microwell
so the benefit of microwell is that you
actually end up with a plate very
similar to what you would do with
microarrays right you have a plate it
has these small
wells on the plate and you're hoping to
put in an individual cell within that
microwell
now this is a process that could be
optimal that could be optimized and you
can see in this case
this is that oil
[Music]
droplet
and here is that little cell right so
that little cell right here uh magnified
over here you can include additional
phenotypic information
so essentially in this case you can make
different color
you know fluorescence and you can
potentially identify an additional
aspect just to give you a control right
but in many cases the limitation of this
technology is that you only have a
certain size right you can have
limitless uh well plates so you have a
limited size
and so
the number of cells is going to be quite
small right so if we're talking about
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
cells you're going to be limited by the
number of well you have and the number
of cells that you're going to
successfully place inside each
individual well
the second technique is called
microfluidics rnac
and so microfluidics really
tries to separate
uh everything again in ap so you have a
plate
and that plate is where you put
your cells inside this area right here
and then they start flowing over here
and as they flow through you can see
that you put in the cells they start
going in and they get trapped and so
these traps right here is where you will
end up having those individual cells
and those cells again are going to be
well these are going to these are going
to be cells that you would hope to then
sequence at the end of the process
because then you can separate them
okay so this is that second
option right when we have microfluidics
the final one and probably one of the
most successful ones is the droplet
single cell rna-seq data preparation and
the idea here is that you have a
continuous flow of drops
and
here you can see that the cell and the
hydrogens are incorporated into here and
as they flow you can monitor them
visually and you can separate the ones
that do have a cell in them or don't
have a cell in them so you have greater
control over this and you have here you
can see that
it kind of encapsulates them into this
oil bead and then you can flow through
and add the barcoding so this is really
a way to scale up and
automate this whole process and so the
idea is that you encapsulate each
individual cell inside a nanoliter drop
it together with the bead then you can
isolate the bead with the enzymes that
are required to construct the library
and each bead will contain that unique
barcode
that because this whole process is going
to be automated right and at the end you
have this ability to separate your reads
into individual cells right and this is
the technology that is going to be used
most often today when you encounter
single cell data for example 10x
genomics is going to be utilizing
something like this